in your opinion what's more important
right
power
influence or money those are three
different things you're saying money
you'd even miss a beat you said money
yeah I like it because with money you
will get power then you get the respect
then you get the girls then you get
whatever everything comes after money
sounds like a little Kim locks video
right here first you get the money then
you get the power then you get the
respect and the [ __ ] so from your
from your perspective Scarface that's
true
I would say
I do believe that with the money you do
get that respect which is going to give
you the influence but I do believe is
the influence what kind of value are you
giving obviously when I was younger and
I didn't have much I always thought it
was money money I feel like people stink
and swear that once they get the money
there that's it like I'll be happy when
you know I'll when I get this I'll be
happy but then when you have influence
and you're able to inspire and give
value and share your story and help
people and actually make an impact to me
that's more fulfilling than money
because I've gotten the money I have the
money yeah I thought I was gonna you
know be the happiest of my life when I
had the money and I wasn't but when I
have influence on someone and I give
them value and I know that I'm genuinely
changing lives and having a positive
impact in someone's lives that's very
that's more fulfilling absolutely yeah
yeah I can appreciate it yeah success
without fulfillment is failure so
obviously you gotta love what you do you
got to be passionate about what you do
but like if you want to get respect you
have to do something worth respecting
absolutely accomplish something make
some money build a business make an
impact serve the people so it all starts
with money at the end of the day people
like to sugarcoat it make some money do
something worth respecting everything
will come after that make some money
people make some money save that money
save that money so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire saucecast
click right here
[Music]